près de deux jours après la disparition
de deux pompiers volontaires de
Saint-Urbain le dénouement tant redouté
ces produits mercredi matin un peu avant
10h ce matin l'hélicoptère de la Sûreté
du Québec au localisé un corps dans le
secteur de Saint-Urbain le nom loin de
la route 138 le corps de Régis Lavoie 55
ans a été retrouvé sur les berges de la
rivière du Gouffre l'opération des
premiers répondants a été délicate ils
ont mis plusieurs heures avant d'arriver
à repêcher son corps peu de temps après
un deuxième corps est aperçu 500 mètres
plus loin celui de Christopher la voix
âgée de 23 ans dans la municipalité de
Saint-Urbain où vivait les deux hommes
c'est le choc
bonjour c'était un jeune homme
exemplaire travaillant
les corps des pompiers ont été retrouvés
tout près du pont de la route 138 là où
ils ont sombre dans la rivière du
Gouffre ces images ont été captées par
une résidence de Saint-Urbain tout
indique que ce sont les deux hommes à
bord d'un véhicule Argo alors qu'il
tentait de porter secours à des citoyens
prisonniers des eaux il semble être dans
la rivière du Gouffre mais ce sont en
réalité des champs inondés en bordure du
cours d'eau les familles des victimes
sont en colère et s'interrogent en
sachant que c'était dangereux qu'il y
avait du courant que Louis était autre
pourquoi ils ont envoyé mon père le cri
du coeur de la fille de Régis Lavoie a
été entendue jusqu'à Québec ça pose des
questions moi c'était mon gage là je les
trouve pas juste troublant je les trouve
inquiétant et il va y avoir des
questions qui vont devoir se poser il va
y avoir des enquêtes qui vont devoir
avoir lieu on est totalement favorable à
une enquête si on juge que c'est
nécessaire pour vraiment faire la
lumière et s'assurer que plus des
situations comme celle-là ne surviennent
de passage à billes Saint-Paul le
Premier ministre s'est montré prudent on
parle d'une situation qui évolué très
vite
mais oui faut se poser des questions
puis on va faire les analyses
nécessaires quant à la mairesse de
Saint-Urbain elle n'a pas souhaité
commenter c'est difficile ce qu'on vit
présentement mais particulièrement pour
les familles qui sont touchées elles
laissent le soin aux policiers de
poursuivre leur enquête sur les
circonstances du décès des deux pompiers
qui selon leurs proches sont morts en
héros ici Camille Carpentier
Radio-Canada Baie-Saint-Paul